we're asked to graph the circle and they
give us this the somewhat crazy looking
equation and then we could graph it
right over here and to graph a circle
you have to know where its center is and
you have to know and you have to know
what its radius is so let me see if I
can change and you have to know it's
radius is so what we need to do is put
this in some form where we can pick out
its center and its radius so let me get
my little scratch pad out and see if we
can do that so this is that same
equation and what I essentially want to
do is I want to complete the square in
terms of X and complete the square in
terms of Y to put it into a form that we
can recognize so first let's take all of
the X terms so let's take all of the X
terms so you have x squared + 4 X on the
left hand side so I could rewrite this
as x squared + 4 X and I'm gonna put
some parentheses around here because I'm
going to complete the square and then I
have my Y terms I'll circle those in
well the red looks too much like the
purple I'll Circle those in blue y
squared and negative 4y so we have plus
plus y squared minus 4y and then we have
a minus 17 and I'll just do that in a
neutral color so minus 17 is equal to 0
now what I want to do is make each of
these purple expressions perfect squares
so how could I do that here well this
would be a perfect square if I took half
of this 4 and I squared it so if I made
this plus 4 then this entire expression
would be X plus 2 squared and you can
verify that if you like we've if if you
need to review on completing the square
there's plenty of videos on Khan Academy
on that all we did is we took half of
this coefficient we took half of this
coefficient and then squared it to get 4
half of 4 is 2 squared to get 4 and that
comes straight out of the idea if you
take x + 2 and square it it's going to
be x squared plus twice the product of 2
and X plus 2 squared now we can't just
really nearly add a 4 here we had an
equality before and just adding a 4
wouldn't it wouldn't be equal anymore so
if we want to maintain the equality we
have to add 4 on the right hand side
well now let's do the same thing for the
Y's half of this coefficient right over
here is a negative two if we square a
negative two it becomes a positive four
we can't just do that on the left hand
side we have to do that on the right
hand side as well now we have in blue
becomes Y minus two squared and of
course we have the minus 17 but why
don't we add 17 to both sides as well to
get rid of this minus 17 here so let's
add 17 on the left and add 17 on the
right so on the left we're just left
with these two expressions and on the
right we have 4 plus 4 plus 17 well
that's 8 plus 17 which is equal to 25
now this is a form that we recognize if
you have the form X minus a squared plus
y minus B squared is equal to R squared
we know that the center we know that the
center is at the point a comma B
essentially the point that makes both of
these equal to 0 and that the radius the
radius is going to be R so if we look
over here what is our a we have to be
careful here our a isn't to our a is
negative 2x minus negative 2 is equal to
2 so the x coordinate of our Center is
going to be negative 2 and the y
coordinate of our Center is going to be
2 remember we care about the x value
that makes this 0 and the y value that
makes this 0 so the center is negative 2
comma 2 and this is the radius squared
so the radius is equal to 5 radius is
equal to 5 so let's go back to the
exercise and actually plot this so it's
negative 2 comma 2 so our Center is
negative 2 comma 2 so that's right over
there X is negative 2 y is positive 2
and the radius is 5 so see this would be
1 2 3 4 5 shifted a little bit wider
than this my my little pen is having
trouble there you go 1 2 3 4 5 let's
check our answer we got it right